merci mme alice bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france alors finalement
le gouvernement irlandais donc qui veut
tabler sur le télétravail conséquence
directe de la pandémie c'est quoi
l'objectif
bonjour à tous très content d'être parmi
vous il ya plusieurs objectifs à travers
cette décision c'est premièrement rendre
le télétravail accessible à beaucoup de
personnes dans les villes mais surtout
hand en dehors des villes dans les
territoires ruraux dans le but également
et c'est la france et où l'arrière
pensée du gouvernement irlandais
d'éviter la désertification de banda
lors de leur région et d'avoir des
villes surpeuplées
ouvrez une vraie piste justement pour
repeupler les campagnes selon vous ce le
recours au télétravail
ces fabuleuses parce que ce qu'on
observait avant même cette crise du coc
vide c'est qu'il y avait énormément de
personnes qui souhaitaient déjà créé
leur activité qui en avaient marre entre
guillemets du mal des villes et qui
souhaitaient sur la prochaine un peu
plus bas des territoires des villages
sûr c'était une grosse tendance alors
clairement la crise que nous traversons
a donné un coup d'accélérateur à tout
ceci
certaines personnes peuvent percevoir le
télétravail comme une punition mais moi
je constate depuis pas mal d'années que
c'est une aspiration chez beaucoup de
personnes n'ont clairement ça serait ça
serait quelque chose de positif
et comment ce que les employés sont
encouragés à télétravailler en irlande
précisément à ce qu'il y avait des
mesures incitatrices qui ont été prises
ou qui pourraient être prises oui oui il
ya pas mal de mesures notamment au
niveau des employeurs pour pouvoir
permettre plus facilement encore un
maximum de personnes de travailler
l'accès à la connexion internet est
évidemment un enjeu crucial pour pouvoir
mettre en place cette stratégie et il ya
sans doute d'autres mesures qui vont
être déclinés au fil des semaines
alors on le voit depuis le début de
cette pandémie il ya aussi beaucoup de
personnes qui ont du mal à à
télétravailler parce qu'il ya des
enfants à la maison comment est ce que
on peut faire de ce télétravail du
gagnant
en soule on vous déjà là c'est vrai que
c'est compliqué je le vis moi même je
travaille de chez moi et vous risquez
d'entendre des enfants qui dure je pense
que ça fait quand même partie de demain
mon choix et c'est que même une chance
de pouvoir consacrer un petit peu de
temps à sa famille on oublie parfois et
puis il ya évidemment une organisation à
mettre en place au niveau de chaque
domicile au niveau de chaque foyer de
trouver des règles de trouver voilà des
manières permettre de l'efficacité
professionnelle aux parents
télétravailleurs ce n'est jamais simple
c'est toujours du cas par cas mais
clairement des solutions existent alors
on parlait de l'irlande qui veut
repeupler ses campagnes notamment grâce
aux au télétravail mais finalement le
télétravail est ce qu'on est plus
efficace en travaillant à la maison est
ce qu'il ya des études est ce que c'est
c'est prouvé où on ne sait pas trop
encore l'efficacité des employés y avait
pas d étude qui donne des chiffres des
tendances précise par rapport à ça
clairement ça présente beaucoup
davantage de pouvoirs télétravail et
j'insiste sur ça c'était déjà une grosse
tendance bien avant le coup vide
énormément de personnes voulaient créer
leur activité de chez elle avant même
d'avoir subi cette cette crise alors oui
il ya plein davantage je ne serait ce
que le temps que l'on passe dans les
transports que l'on élimine ya moins de
pression forcément à l'ordre ensuite il
peut y avoir quelques inconvénients des
journées qui vont durer un peu plus
longtemps parce qu'on prend un peu plus
de liberté pendant la journée il ya des
réflexes organisationnel adopté à mettre
en place
tout ceci ça prend tout ceci se
maîtrisent mais une fois qu'on arrive à
finir la bonne combinaison
je pense qu'en termes d'épanouissement
la majorité des personnes se retrouvent
gagnante une fois qu'elle passe au
télétravail vous parlez des personnes
qui veulent créer leur activité mais
celles qui travaillent pour des
entreprises est ce que c'est possible
aussi de de privilégier le télétravail
on prend le cas de l'irlande toujours
qui veut mettre en place des centres
dédiés justement à ce télétravail dans
les campagnes oui mais oui c'est bien
évidemment que possible la clé c'est
l'organisation c'est ce qui va être
remis en place discuter entre
l'entreprise et le travailleur en
question en termes d'attentes c'est
fabuleux que des relents puisse donner
plus
deux possibilités à ces personnes là
d'avoir des endroits de connexion des
endroits pour pouvoir travailler donc
clairement c'est possible a aussi
l'organisation au niveau du domicile est
évidemment un élément crucial mais
j'insiste sur le fait qu'en terme
davantage c'est simplement fabuleux
alors en irlande on parle de l'état qui
pousse à télétravailler mais qu'est ce
qu'il en est des entreprises et les
chefs d'entreprise irlandais notamment
est ce que eux aussi ils poussent à
télétravailler oui clairement il y avait
une grosse poussée depuis plusieurs mois
un petit peu comme tout le monde et le
fait d'avoir un petit peu l'état qui
tous à leurs côtés ça va permettre de
donner une impulsion encore plus grande
de donner plus de facilité à certaines
entreprises pour pouvoir voilà mettre en
place le télétravail avec certains
employés encore plus facilement
c'est voilà c'est la combinaison des
deux c'est une aspiration c'est une
volonté des entreprises où je dirais
même détroit et d'hommes avec le support
du gouvernement parce que ça coûte moins
cher à une entreprise d'avoir un
télétravailleur salah coûte moins cher
effectivement il ya des réductions et
des optimisations qui peuvent se faire
au niveau des espaces à louer ou loués
par l'entreprise pour pouvoir gérer son
activité alors clairement pouvoir
éliminer certaines charges même si elles
seront peut être compensée en partie par
d'autres liées au télétravail sa
présente un avantage financier est ce
qu'il n'ya pas un risque du courroux une
tentation pour les entreprises
finalement est bien d'aller à embaucher
dans un autre pays où le coût du travail
il serait évidemment moins cher c'est
déjà le cas aujourd'hui donc au final il
ya énormément de fonction qui ne peuvent
pas être externalisés à l'autre bout du
monde et celles qui le sont qu'ils
peuvent l'être sont déjà externalisé
on le voit au niveau de certains codes
cinq heures aujourd'hui on est au niveau
de certaines usines qui peuvent produire
à l'étranger donc de ce point de vue là
je ne pense pas que ce soit un risque je
vois vraiment ça comme une opportunité
merci beaucoup nassim a nice je rappelle
que vous êtes consultant et auteur du
livre
tout le monde mérite de travailler
en pantoufles